how many nutshells could you take right
before truly it's you know you're done
you're too numb
he's asking for a friend
[Laughter]
I could take about
four five that's a lot a lot during the
sixth grade somebody threw a basketball
and hit me right now that was done for
the week what's that are you talking
about with the cup on in a fight are you
talking about straight up nut shot I'm
just straight up nutshot oh no you're
out let's say you're at the Grove okay
go to Banana Republic right like I could
use a new uh you know jacket of some
sort maybe a bomber maybe chinos maybe
some chinos and uh some kids walk by
some YouTube kids right trying to get
their page going and they're like yo
Ryan Garcia let's see how many yo I'm
here yo hey how many shots can you take
before you know I'm crazy handy let's
see I'm crazy
I could take four yeah four I could take
four times
just estimating here